Alors, lequel je vais mettre aujourd'hui ?
J'hésite un peu...
En revanche, ce qui doit devenir un reflexe,
C'est la manière dont on pose et dont on retire le masque.
D'abord, on commence par se laver les mains avec du gel hydroalcoolique ou du savon.
J'ai déjà fait une capsule de déconfiné sur le sujet.
Puis, on repère le haut du masque.
C'est facile :
certains d'entre-eux sont en plus équipés d'une barrette métallique, c'est encore plus simple.
On pose le masque sur le visage,
Puis, on passe les élastiques.
On vérifie que le nez et la bouche sont bien recouverts jusqu'au menton.
On sert la barrette.
Et voilà !
Je suis prêt pour sortir.
Attention, tant que le masque est posé sur le visage,
On évite d'y toucher.
Quand on rentre à la maison maintenant :
On commence par se laver les mains.
Puis on retire le masque en manipulant uniquement les élastiques ou le lien en fonction du modèle.
S'il s'agit d'un masque jetable, comme celui-ci,
Vous le mettez dans un sac poubelle,
Qu'il est préférable de mettre dans un second sac poubelle
Pour éviter les risques de déchirure au moment de la collecte.
Et, bien sûr,
Vous vous relavez les mains.
S'il s'agit d'un masque lavable, comme celui-ci,
Surtout, vous ne le mélangez pas avec le reste du linge,
Vous le mettez à part.
Le jour de la lessive,
Vous mettez le ou les masques dans la machine
Et vous effectuez un rinçage rapide avec quelques gouttes d'eau de javel.
Puis, vous glissez les masques au milieu des draps de bain, des serviettes et des gants
Pour assurer le côté mécanique du lavage.
Et vous faites tourner à une température comprise entre 60 et 90°C.
Quand c'est terminé, vous retirez les masques
Et vous les mettez au sèche-linge
Ou vous les séchez au sèche-cheveux.
Vous pouvez à nouveau porter les masques.
Alors je sais, ça fait beaucoup de choses à retenir,
Mais pas de panique, ça va finir par rentrer !
Et puis, si jamais vous avez un trou,
De mémoire hein, pas dans le masque !
Et bien, vous pouvez revoir cette capsule de déconfiné
Ou consulter le site de l'AFNOR, l'Association Française de NORmalisation
Bon alors, lequel je mets...
Celui-ci n'a pas l'air mal...
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Allez, à demain !
Et n'oubliez pas,
Nous sommes toujours confinés (ça ne va pas durer),
Mais on reste en lien !!
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
N'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir toutes celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
Pour être sûr de n'en louper aucune,
Et bien, abonnez-vous,
et activez la petite cloche.